trois mois après le début de son évasion
en ukraine la russie concentre ses
efforts sur le dombass ces derniers
jours l'armée russe a redéployé ses
troupes dans cette région de l'est des
soldats sont arrivés en provenance des
environs de kharkiv et marioupol suivi
par des miliciens séparatistes ou encore
des combattants tchétchènes les combats
seraient intenses dans les régions de
louhansk et donne y est pour faire le
point sur cette situation en ukraine on
retrouve l'un de nos envoyés spéciaux
cyril payen bonjour cyril avec mohamed
fahd vous vous trouvez à irbine cette
banlieue de kiev dans laquelle vous
aviez tourné au début de la guerre vous
êtes retourné on a pu voir votre
reportage ce matin dans l'ouest de cette
région de kiev occupé pendant des
semaines par l'armée russe de terrible
témoignage d'exactions commencent à
faire surface
oui effectivement et cela donne une idée
assez terrifiante glaçante on a du mal à
trouver le au réel quand on parcourt ces
dizaines de kilomètres qui séparent la
capitale kiev de la frontière biélorusse
c'est là effectivement que la guerre a
commencé c'est là que ces unités de
l'armée russe ont sont entrées via la
biélorussie pour l'invasion de l'ukraine
c'était il ya trois mois presque jour
pour jour et c'est vrai que l'idée selon
les témoignages glaçant qu on a pu
recueillir qui font état d'exécutions
sommaires de disparitions de mineurs
deux jeunes garçons qui sont qui ont été
emmenés comme des trophées c'est ce
qu'on nous a dit mais également et
surtout le viol utilisé comme arme de
guerre sur des centaines de femmes des
dizaines d'hommes dont des témoignages
qui commencent à émerger mais surtout
qui donne évidemment un éclairage sur la
réalité de cette invasion russe à
l'occupation russe dans ces zones qui
ont été occupées pendant des semaines
alors que les villes résidentiel 1
l'ouest de kiev résister absolument
vaillamment brillamment pour repousser
l'invasion russe mais ça donne aussi une
idée de ce qui se passe actuellement en
chine et à l'est dans le ton basse temps
l'eau place dans la région
administrative de harkis aussi on peut
imaginer l'horreur qui se passe
actuellement au moment où on parle un
trois mois après le début de la guerre
dans ces régions où il ya une occupation
militaire russe cette sa hausse et hossa
aussi dont il s'agit dans cette
opération militaire russe alors on va
rentrer effectivement dans le temps le
quatrième mois oui voilà des mercedes
qui doit s'exprimer donc aujourd'hui à
davos alors que la diplomatie est donc
au point mort les combats font rage à
l'est et on entre dans le quatrième mois
de guerre dans une atmosphère mitigé
oui effectivement on sent bien ici nous
qui sommes revenus après avoir passé
trois semaines au début de la guerre
dans une sorte d'entre deux on est un
peu à la croisée des chemins en fait
personne n'a vraiment gagné la guerre
mais personne ni dans un candidat en
date de la véritablement eu perdu on
voit bien que kiev évidemment la sau ton
l'admirent poutine avait avait pensé
qu'il serait extrêmement rapide et que
kiev tomberait comme un grand symbole eh
bien ça on sait c'est un échec on sait
que la deuxième phase de cette opération
militaire spéciale dans l'île dans là
évidemment l'imagerie militaire russe
était l'offensive sur karkhiv bien là
aussi il ya eu des combats intenses et
une occupation et puis une
contre-offensive de l'armée ukrainienne
alors c'est ça aussi la grande nouveauté
c'est que l'armée ukrainienne des forces
de défense territoriale tous ces
volontaires qui ont vaillamment résisté
et est dans une posture purement
défensive pendant des semaines là on est
déjà on le voit bien à kharkiv dans de
la contre-offensive voir dans
l'offensive d'actifs mais c'est là aussi
et c'est l'histoire qui jugera
évidemment l'implication de tel ou tel
état dans la communauté internationale
et bien que la ligne de partage qui
sépare les états de l'occident notamment
pour aider militairement pour soutenir
jusqu'au bout l'offensive ou un contre
offensive ukrainienne et les athées et
les et rosetta plus attentiste qui
prévilégie la médiation et qui ne
veulent pas nécessairement soins c'est
la russie on est vraiment dans cette
drôle de guerre actuellement avec pour
terminer la ville où nous nous trouvons
avec mohamed farhat ou kiev tente coûte
que coûte après avoir résisté entrer
dans un mode de résilience malgré une
inflation importante malgré un manque de
tout malgré la guerre qui fait rage vous
disiez très justement à 600 km heure on
se trouve eh bien les habitants tu
kiffes les habitants de l'ouest de
l'ukraine tente de reprendre la vie
c'est l' aussie aussie aussie cette
manière de résister à cette invasion
militaire russe qui a commencé il ya
bientôt maintenant quatre mois
cyril payen depuis hier pin en ukraine
merci beaucoup cyril et merci à mohamed
saâd donc est avec vous